Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis avec
Anthony de la chaîne Brut2capteur.
Brut2capteur, une chaîne dédiée aux débutants on va dire en photographie.
C'est à dire que avant les débutants y a moi, en fait.
Oh nan.
Oh si !  -Nan, tu m'as parlé d'ouverture et tout c'est bien.
Ah oui, c'est vrai mais moi je régurgite des mots.
Moi je suis capable de retenir tous les mots, tu sais.
Et passer pour un expert de l'automobile en 5 secondes devant de ton garagiste.
Mais bien sûr, je fais ça en plus.
J'ai bien aimé ce que tu faisais, je trouvais ça cool et puis on a eu un bon feeling,
on a échangé et qu'est ce qui va se passer ? Bah il va se faire mentaliser !
Tu vas te faire mentaliser, par moi mais par eux aussi.
Vous êtes prêts à essayer ?
Je vais t'emmener dans un univers particulier, un univers que je crois que tu ne connais pas
mais qui est pourtant en lien avec la photo.
Tu vas travailler pour Voilà, c'est un nouveau magazine,  c'est un mélange de [ensemble] Voici et Gala.
Et tu vas aller faire une paparazzade. Quoique non je crois que une paparazzade c'est quand les people
organisent eux-mêmes un truc de paparazzi.
- Alors nan tu vas faire le paparazzi, simplement le paparazzi.
Tu vas aller photographier une star, quelqu'un qu'on connait.
J'ai qu'une contrainte c'est que ce soit quelqu'un de français.
Par contre ça peut être de n'importe quel univers, me dit pas encore lequel, tu vas avoir des noms qui vont commencer à te venir.
C'est déjà fait. - C'est vrai ? Tu sais déjà ?
Ouais je sais déjà. - Ah c'est formidable !
Alors je vais juste te changer le plan de caméra, pour qu'on puisse bien voir tes regards.
C'est quelqu'un de français ? - C'est quelqu'un de français. - Super.
F : Tu veux te voir ? A : Nan nan, sans façon.
F : Donc tu as un people en tête, ça t'es venu assez spontanément apparemment.
F : Je vais te poser des questions et eux vont t'observer en même temps que moi,
on va tout regarder, je vais essayer en même temps de désigner des points sur ton visage.
A : Ahah, des yeux
(bruits et rires)
F : Le mec il se fait analyser ! Ne bougez pas, jeune homme.
Première question, qui est une affirmation, mais je vérifie encore une fois, c'est quelqu'un de français.
A : Oui, on est d'accord.
F : Donc quelqu'un qui parle français.
A : On est d'accord.
F : Ok.
Vous avez vu ? Quand il dit "On est d'accord", il penche un petit peu ici.
Donc c'est sa manière de dire oui.
Je vais te poser des questions à partir de maintenant, tu vas me répondre mais que dans ta tête,
dans ta tête à toi, sans rien me dire.
Est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui est dans le milieu artistique, quel qu'il soit ?
Le milieu large de la télévision jusqu'au cinéma en passant par la scène.
A : Oui.
F : Sans répondre...mais t'as répondu.
A : Ah oui, quel tocard ! On la refait ?
F : On a gagné une réponse !
C'est bon ça. D'accord, merci ! Ça nous, ça...
En fait, c'est un petit peu un Akinator que je suis en train d'essayer de faire pour commencer.
Alors, tu sais quoi, au lieu de te poser des questions, je vais faire des affirmations
et tu peux les commenter dans ta tête.
A : Très bien.
F : Tu les commentes juste là, pas là, juste là.
Mon affirmation c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui est souvent sur scène, en fait.
Vous avez vu ? Cette petite déception juste là dans le regard ?
Donc ça, ça veut dire non.
Mais mon affirmation c'est que c'est quelqu'un qu'on voit souvent au cinéma, par contre.
Et là, vous avez vu ? Ça s'est plus passé ici, au niveau des lèvres,
ça s'est légèrement remonté, donc pour moi on est sur quelqu'un du cinéma.
On a un petit oui qui traine, c'est parfait.
Je dirais que c'est soit un homme...soit une femme.
Ok, on a vu qu'il est revenu au repos au niveau de la femme, donc c'est un homme.
A : (rires)
F : Alors, si vous avez vu ma vidéo sur le détecteur de mensonges, on avait la créativité ici, la mémoire ici,
il vient d'aller en haut à droite, donc ça ça veut dire que t'étais en train de reprendre une image visuelle de ta mémoire.
Par quel chemin je vais aller trouver ? Ah bah tiens, tu sais quoi, on va essayer de trouver la première lettre de son prénom.
Première lettre de son prénom, t'y penses.
Tu vas regarder le capteur, s'il-te-plaît.
Et quand tu entendras la lettre, tu crieras STOP dans ta tête.
Mais dans ta tête, uniquement.
C'est parti ! Ça peut être
A B C D E F G H I J K L M N O P Q R S T U V W X Y Z
On a eu les yeux sur le P, et la bouche sur le V.
Donc ça doit être P ou V.
En fait, c'est plutôt cool de le faire...
A : T'es une machine, Olicard !
Les deux : (rires)
F : Cet homme est une machine ! Il n'est pas humain...
Ok, prénom masculin qui commence par un V...
...je commence à avoir des idées.
Ok, j'ai un ressenti, moi j'ai un feeling avec toi.
Je vais essayer de l'écrire ici et de leur faire voir.
Je vais le faire même sur l'ardoise, ça sera plus sympa.
A : C'est fou...
F : Confirme bien que tu ne vois pas l'écran, que l'écran est retourné vers moi.
A : Je ne vois pas l'écran.
F : Qu'on pense pas que tu puisses lire ce que je mets.
Je dirais que c'est ça...
J'écris très mal ! Ne cherchez pas d'embrouilles sur ce que j'écris, j'écris juste très mal.
Voilà sur quel acteur je m'arrête moi. C'est presque un coup de bluff.
Alors encore une fois, j'ai essayé de vous emmener au départ sur le terrain pour essayer de le faire en même temps que moi
mais j'ai un peu envie de vous bluffer aussi !
Donc je viens d'écrire quelque chose ici,
est-ce que tu peux me dire quel acteur t'étais en train de photographier derrière ton buisson de paparazzi ?
A : C'était bien sûr Vincent Cassel.
F : Vincent Cassel !
A : T'es une machine, c'est génial, oh la vache !
C'était vraiment super, voilà bah, bluffé comme tous les autres forcément.
F : C'est vrai, ça t'as plu ?
A : Ouais ouais ouais, très très très très fort.
Le V, le V, c'était wow ! Pourtant j'ai essayé vraiment de ne rien laisser paraître sur le V,
bon je suppose que je suis lisible comme un livre ouvert, mais bon !
Tu le verras là, pour le coup c'est chouette.
Après, j'ai aussi pris en compte ton âge, des choses un peu particulières.
Si vous allez sur sa chaîne, ce que je vous recommande, je vous mets la petite fiche juste là,
vous allez voir dans sa vidéo de présentation, Anthony il explique qu'il a 27 ans,
si on regarde dans ses anciennes playlists de vidéos, on voit tout ce qui est l'univers du hard rock.
Ça donne aussi beaucoup d'indices sur qui tu peux être. - Bien sûr.
Sur ce que je pourrais aimer, sur ce que je pourrais choisir.
Tu vois, moi je pense que David Hoberman, pour le coup...
Exactement, voilà, c'était ma première...ma première pensée en fait !
Merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette vidéo.
Allez découvrir la chaîne d'Anthony,
donc c'est sur le tuto photo, moi j'y connais rien en photo et j'apprend pleins de truc grâce à sa chaîne
et voilà, merci ! Merci de ce que tu fais pour nous.
Mais je t'en prie, merci de m'avoir accueilli, c'était une expérience unique, je voulais vraiment la vivre en plus !
Parce que on le voit en vidéo et on se dit toujours, est-ce qu'il n'y a pas une complicité, est-ce que etc...
Et c'est vraiment bluffant. - Cool !
Merci Fabien pour ce petit moment de plaisir.
Chouette ! Si ça vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à nous en parler, à laisser un petit commentaire.
Je dis "nous" parce qu'il viendra lire les commentaires, c'est sûr, c'est certain.
N'hésitez pas également à nous laisser un petit
pouce en l'air !
Vous pouvez également vous abonnez à la chaîne si c'est pas fait,
vous pouvez partager cette vidéo,
bref faites ce que vous voulez, rendez demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !